[Music]
Europe has now become the epicenter of
the corona virus pandemic and the
European Parliament stands ready to
support all necessary measures to combat
the outbreak governments across the EU
have taken unprecedented steps to slow
the progress of the disease social
distancing policies like school closures
staying at home and avoiding crowds are
vital tools in the fight against the
virus that's an extraordinary video
summit EU leaders decided to temporarily
close the e use external and Schengen
borders to non-essential travel they
also agreed to coordinate the
repatriation of EU citizens stranded
outside the bloc Parliament's welcomed
the EU response union repay a stock or
agenda multi gooeys me sobre to toliman
casa di gordon amento tragg of any
nationality from teh ala gravy crystal
cove additional timonium Oh finalmente
condo spirit OD solidary de Courcey
referentiality pasado the material image
is officially a libera Chief collection
Adele emerges will not throw territorial
the so-called Green Lanes will ensure
that vital goods and medical equipments
continue to circulate freely within the
EU Parliament will also vote on measures
to mitigate the economic impact of the
crisis the EU coordinated response
includes a 37 billion euro package to
provide financial support for the
healthcare sector but also for
businesses and people so that income and
jobs are protected and the European
Central Bank announced a 750 billion
euro plan to stem the impact on the EU s
economy buying government and corporates
bonds Parliament's will hold an
extraordinary session in Brussels to
speed up implementation and deliver
results quickly
[Music]